it's 400 miles to asna
long where to go for a party
they said david we're lost that's the
time no it's not this is the time no
david blood is stupid
it was an accident
stepped out in front of us we didn't
want the police showing up
poking their noses into everything
you got into a car with a drunk which
makes you an accessory
like i've been an accessory for a long
time now
now listen are you going to mobile
weekend why are you going to enjoy
yourself it's not a clown you enjoy
yourself you know
i suppose i could make the effort
did you mention money
no
he wants you to return with them to bury
the boy it is customary in these parts
people disappear here they just vanish
you
[Music]
what did you do with this id
barrier
they didn't just hit him
they ran over him
maybe more than once
what did they call it in your country
roadkill
there's nowhere to run nowhere to hide
says it occurred to you that he might
actually be planning something a lot
nastier than anything you can anticipate
you've forgotten about my husband
yes i have and so with you
[Music]
why did you come here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you